women smell so wonderful I'm actually  doing a piece on motherhood really did  you know amniotic fluid is actually  urine let's open that wine we're having  a baby - yay how far along are you  I'm not actually pregnant we have a  surrogate I'm Kiki I'm Wayne and Tina's  baby surrogate mom did you screw  surrogate whoa I think Donna's boning  someone else okay suppose is take care  of course I care there are five phases  of a woman's life I am in phase four you  have to be a mother if government and  businesses are gonna devalue women's  work and make motherhood economically  unfeasible why not outsource it see this  is why people hate liberals huh I made  fresh orange juice for Karen folic acid  [Music]  Tina is like a sperm donor  I'm so not like a sperm donor  [Music]  you